hello everyone and Happy New Year
everyone and by New Year I don't mean
the night or the day you've spent
partying or chillin at home but I mean
the entire 2019 I hope everything works
out for you and that you achieve
everything you you set for yourself now
before we check out this game it's also
again from the 2018 world blitz
championship we already mentioned that
the unchurched of dudepls Grandmaster a
very young Grandmaster I think he's 19
or maybe 20 played a spectacular
tournament but he was overshadowed by by
Magnus Carlsen well beyond impressive
performance but he was also well we're
gonna check out the standings after the
game but also very very deservedly you
know second place almost first place
half point behind Magnus Carlsen really
just an incredible game but before we
check out the game I would like to
address a certain issue about about my
channel now just you know thinking about
the entire 2018 and how this channel
grew and improved and well hard to say
if it improved but it did change and
most everything you see the the
interface what has been added the format
of the videos the length of the videos
it's mostly everything that well you
either liked or disliked or suggested
and this is the combined the ideas of
each and every one of you is now
basically this and I remember a few
years back there was this YouTube
channel it's called the master media he
creates an animation small mostly dragon
blurry related and when he started he
really had a really impressive growth
when he started out his channel and then
after after some time he created a video
how I how I gained two hundred thousand
or maybe two hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers in one year and I was I was
really impressed with this number I was
like wow that's that's so impressive and
yesterday I I went and checked well the
entire 2018 how much our community has
grown on this channel and I was I was
very impressed and now if I asked you
how
many subscribers do you think this
channel brought together in the entire
2018 if I said you now pick a number
what number would you pick well I'm
gonna show you the exact number is sorry
not to that 267 thousands and 96 so this
is a we are at three hundred and forty
seven thousand s now but most of most of
the channels growth happened in 2018 so
two hundred and sixty-seven thousand
subscribers that is well when I think a
year back and what my expectations were
and everything this is a beyond my
wildest dreams especially since when I
compared it to when master media made it
that video about how he grew so much in
one year I mean there are so many more
fans of animation and Dragon Ball in the
world them there are fans of chess that
that's why I'm so much more impressed
but yeah once again I would like to
thank each and every one of you for for
you know every every comment you made
every like you dropped every to each and
every one of you that has subscribed and
made this channel what it is today and
you know two for recommending it to your
friends to your students perhaps I don't
know I've met when I was in London
during the World Chess Championship
match between Carson Curran I may I met
Grandmaster David Howell and I said to
him like you know how you doing and
everything and I didn't think he knew
like why was he actually knew who I was
and he said that his students are big
fans of mine and I was like why would
why would your students be fans of me as
they have a grandmaster teaching them
but yeah really really weird but yeah
that's basically what I wanted to say
really thank you so much for everything
now let's get back to this game and hope
we can continue in this fashion
throughout the entire 2019 and and
onward but yeah let's check it out young
she stopped do de oppose Grand Master
has the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to f3
so the reti opening as the title would
suggest it's interesting I don't know
how many players were influenced by
alpha zeros players alpha if you just
let alpha play whatever it wants and
then alpha will always go for the for
the ready I believe which kind of does
make sense I mean you haven't ruined
your pawn structure you know once you
move the pawn forward you can no longer
ever move it backwards so knife to f3
doesn't really ruin the position you can
always move it back if you don't like it
on f3 so it kind of does make sense okay
d5 by 11 we have c4 the Reta gambit now
which is of course always declined with
d6 you don't want to capture it if you
capture then you just abandon your
center white can immediately attack it
and there's really no good way to defend
it you're gonna have to play some weird
moves to defend it the Queen will also
join the attack and then if you really
want to play silly moves you can go b5
and then a four attacks the structure
and so on and so on but white will
always be better here over ok c4 e6
onion declines this gambit III Knight to
f6 we have nice the c3 Bishop to e7
prepares castling and b3 I do that wants
the fianchettoed the light square Bishop
the dark square Bishop c5 and Nazi
captors on d5 ECAP for Sunday 5 and now
Bishop to b2 nice to see six are in and
continues developing and we have d4 and
Bishop to g4 Bishop to e2 and now comes
Bishop captures on f3 a series of
exchanges Bishop captures on f3 see
capture some d4 CT capture some before
and now castles this might seem a bit
unambitious for for black first
exchanging here on f3 then exchanging in
the center and we always say that the
take is a mistake e if you're not
gaining anything then you shouldn't
trade you've just improved the position
of the light square bishop also the
white didn't black didn't really gain
anything with the exchange in the center
but it's it's blitz so most likely it it
doesn't matter all that much okay the
castles we have Queen to
seven and now a three taking away this
be Foursquare from blacks knife but also
preparing before as see five will be a
very important outpost for for this
night when it finally gets their push up
to d8 we have nightly for preparing this
jump also releasing the bishop now Queen
to f5 and here we have rook to e1 not
allowing this knife to come to e4 Bishop
to b6 and now comes b4 rook F to e8
opposing White's rook on the open file
and the Knights the c5 and here Duda
would be very happy if argument would
actually capture this night this would
create this well monster bishop as now
it would be the strongest piece on the
board we can say and with the Bishop
repair it white would be much better but
we have rook capture Sonny won Queen
captures anyone and not rook to e8
attacking the Queen and Queen to be one
here dude offers a trade of Queens and
Aragon declines it and as well he should
if you capture the rod captures then
black black has a lot of weaknesses the
b7 pawn is weak if we already said if
you capture then white will get a really
powerful dark square bishop and the
bishop pair the game is played on both
sides of the board it will be stronger
than the knight spare the d5 pawn is
somewhat weak here nighties can start
defending it's there on d5 but only no
uh definitely a good decision by 11 not
going for the exchange Queen to f4 and
now comes the Queen to d3
now also Duda has to bring the only
undeveloped piece into the game h6
making some breathing room for the King
you don't want any back ranked
weaknesses to be a problem as it is a
blitz game g3 do that does the same also
create some room and g2 for for the
White King also the King will be
protecting the bishop on f3
Queen back to c7 and now rook to c1 you
can't go rook to e1 just yet as d1
square is unguarded but the rook is very
nicely placed on c1 opposing that Queen
on c7 Queen back to e7
now with the Queen rook battery 11 has
very nice control of the entire efile
and now King to g2
and here it's not easy for black to make
a plan 11 play tonight to the eight he
wants the Riemann over this tonight the
e6 to try and increase pressure in the
center and also perhaps the trade of
this night for a night but not by
capturing and c5 it's interesting if you
could go Knight to e4 you might
definitely want to go Knight to e4 but
after rook to e1 attacking the knight f5
it seems like you have a really
excellent outpost for the night
if white wants white can trade but then
black will be better but after Bishop to
h5 you're not really ready to handle
this f3 move not not yet of course
because the rook on e1 is unprotected
and black and always capture and c5
would which would come with an attack
against the white queen as well but it's
a it's a just a long-term liability so
Knights the d8 1100 wants to go to e6
now we have rook to c2
you can't oppose this battery via rook
to e1 as d1 square is unguarded so look
to see - and then the rook is coming to
e2 which is guarded by the bishop and
the Queen 96 as planned and now rook to
e2 now of course this creates a very
powerful pin but well it is a blitz game
and in blitz anything can happen in this
position Levin had like 10 seconds on
the clock when he made his next move he
should play Queen c7 get the Queen out
of this nasty pin and then simply
continue the game but he decided to go
for Knight captures on c5 this was one
of the reasons he decided to go for this
maneuver now yes the rook can capture
the Queen but there is also an attack
against dudas Queen on d3 but Knight
captures on c5 is a terrible blunder
that loses the game so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
move Duda played to finish this game for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations it means that you are
sharp minded and were not partying hard
yesterday and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show do the plate D
captures on c5 and it was in this
position that 11 aragon resigned the
game
what if you resign well his queen is
under attack he has to move the Queen
and once you move the Queen it doesn't
matter what where you move the Queen
obviously you can move
the Queen anywhere let the Queen d7
white will simply capture after black
captures Queen captures here then black
loses the bishop on b6 there is no way
you can avoid losing the piece here so
yeah I mean the piece is under attack
and also the queen is under attack it's
a terrible terrible move but yeah you
might wonder and this is something you
know people always wonder how come when
I play against an opponent my opponent
is so strong always plays the strongest
moves always it's like my opponent is
alpha 0 and here Aragon who is a much
higher rated than Duda in blitz Aragon
is over 2850 Radin in blitz plays a move
like Knight captures on c5 it's it might
seem weird that at 2850 player would do
such a thing but that's doodle dooing
that's a funny saying that's doodles
doing but it is I mean when you force
your opponent to make the best move move
after move after move for 425 moves and
he runs out of time even a 2850 player
will make a move like nice captures on
c5 and it doesn't mean do that was lucky
it just means that our onion in this
game could not continue taking this
pressure sir D captures on c5 RN and
resigns and a wonderful victory for the
Polish Grandmaster young Chiefs of Duda
so also I prepared this so we don't
forget about it as we already shown have
shown Kostas opponents in this entire
world blitz championship left shoulder
those opponents so these are all the
opponents Duda faced during the 2018
world blitz championship he started off
with three victories against Vladimir
silver stuff Pavel Potapov and the
bodies grachev then a draw against very
strong Dmitry and raking then Alou a
loss to Peter Svidler then a victory
against the international master from
seed invoke Edith then again a loss
against magnus carlsen then a draw
against Alexander Alianza ideas ancef
and then he started his amazing winning
streak which I believe it's eight wins
in a row so a victory against McHale the
meat of Gregorio purring maxi Matlock of
Nikita with you go young upon yashi
Vladislav artemiev Levin onion and
Gawain Jones and
it was a Sergei Carrigan who ended his
winning streak but only with a draw then
one loss against the current Nakamura
and then he continues winning up until
the end of the tournament he beats
onigiri he beats Serbian grandmaster
Alexander English and finishes all the
tournament with a very nice victory
against the Boris Gelfand and in the end
we already shown this but there you have
it the interest of Duda in second place
you know really making a name for Poland
in the chess world
I mean Poland's has always been a very
strong country in chess world you know
think of a key barb in Spain for example
but as you can see the only the only
Polish flag in the first 25 players I
believe so now Magnus Carlsen 17 points
do the sixteen and a half and then third
he Cara Nakamura so young she's tough
Duda to two full points ahead of Hikaru
Nakamura who you know of course is the
bull the the speed demon that is quite
quite an impressive achievement for the
Polish Grandmaster so that's it for this
video I do hope you enjoyed it once
again thank you everyone for everything
in 2018 hope we're gonna have another
excellent year I would like to thank
evolve god of all going Ehlinger
Christian Humphries Oliver Kramer
Roger reap and Kevin Hoffman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon I believe we are starting the
kappa blanka saga tomorrow and maybe if
i will find the time maybe we'll have a
nice stream today but we'll see how that
goes thank you all and I will see you
soon